[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another awesome episode of the careful
boys we got a careful boy guest right
here dante bosco and building
[Applause]
[Music]
the dog really wanted to know
we were just talking about head in the
clouds and it was it was a [ __ ] crazy
week right and the clouds what is it
exactly explain to me this musical
festival that's put on by 88 rising at
the record label that not only hosts and
promotes a lot of uh asian asian
american talent but now they've even
broken 40 000 asian kids they don't they
don't care about us they don't invite us
to [ __ ] [ __ ] idiot i've been to some
of the indian rising stuff the the
chinese new year stuff or lunar new
year's stuff is pretty dope
go and say say your piece today
not finished okay cool yeah hey anthony
i saw that head in the clouds the kenjas
were there and my favorite you guys
performed there dude all red leather
jackets you know and matching is this
how many day festival is it it's in l.a
two-day festival it's like asian
coachella yeah
it's it was at brookside golf course at
the rose bowl was it really i'm playing
brookside on monday i love i like
brookside i'm playing it monday when i
saw you guys perform i was like do you
guys just show up at like the men's
warehouse and be like can i get 12 red
pets
and then they're like that is all the
red pants we got
you already know that men's warehouse
doesn't have that look
which one the red panther the king
aesthetic they went to fire tonight do
you guys are you guys taylor gang or you
guys gotta go you shop and find where
you guys go burlington coat factory half
and half house they go to chinatown i
only know that because you know i come
from a break dancing group and i know we
all had we always my mom made some more
stuff look and then some it's hard again
you need 12 of the same costumes with
guys on different body types you know
what i mean like you got you got yeah
you got to work with both but the
jackets are custom because i see the
kenja's in the back custom so the jacks
were custom everything else we had to
put together piece by piece and figure
things out the t-shirts which are maroon
we got one of them little five for ten
shops wow
i didn't know they still existed pro
club were they shaka's hanes lululemon
wow
but you gotta get extra large because
fashion nova is like them skinny you
know urban look and stuff like that
plus you guys are dancing so you need
some material
that has some stretch
or you're gonna have a little bit
four-way stretch and they got quick
shipping and those those pants are like
21 they don't really need stretchy
clothing they don't do that much you
know
so you spend hella money
you spend for us we spent a hell of
money and and resources just be standing
here
to put things like a custom jacket
together
that's the hot part and then you got to
make sure the shoes are obviously ill
you know we got these like nike utility
boots and stuff like everything else we
try to save money on yeah everything
else as long as it fits right
how is it like performing in front of 40
000 people was that sick the stage looks
sick you know what's interesting i think
uh because after like what [ __ ] a
decade of getting on big stages and
stuff like that
festivals are always fun and unique but
they're never like the most appropriate
for like a dance performance one the
live feed always has some sort of lag
music to video
and then two when there's like giant
barricades and stuff like that there's
kind of a disconnect right you like even
if you're at the front of the stage
you're still like 30 feet away from like
the closest fans
so so the actual energy is a very unique
experience you're just more like a sea
of people and that is cool and 80 of
people are on drugs or just eating a hot
dog
yeah but i feel like what one of the
sickest things or at least like what
we've been experiencing this year alone
by way of performing things like
coachella and head and clouds is just
being the only dance crew on an entire
lineup of musician that's true cause you
can finally rub it
you could finally rub it in our faces
that
hey you're only in vegas
but like you know what we're actually
doing
festivals [ __ ] now we can't use
this video anthony
okay first of all
is he shot up jab jab jab walk is ghost
for that okay
this whole guy is still different
hey that's the wrong hat that's the
wrong hat
get out of here y'all
oh my goodness
wow whoa with overalls and abiding hat
bro
give us your breath break down real
quick this fool got no shoes or socks on
you're the magawackies
you got you did both sides we're just
keeping it equal oh my god where are we
going what's happening dante's like
where are we going what's happening
right now so we're just getting variety
um shout out to the job but that is cool
though that you guys are like you guys
are put in the same like
um i guess the same realm as a
performing artist that's what i'm saying
that that's so weird to me because you
know like to to see an entire lineup of
musicians like establish incredible
musicians right people coming from
[ __ ] like korea and stuff like that
people have been in the game for like a
long time and people like dumbfoundead
coachella i'm all over the i mean you
got the highest of the high at coachella
it's so cool you feel like you don't
belong with those names um
no it just feels like uh moving the
needle for like the dance community yeah
i feel like it's a no-brainer for you
guys to be up there no i'm proud
i come from the world you know but
frozen actor i was a p boy like that was
what we did so when
[ __ ] started popping like jab walkers on
abc quest crew cabba
kenji's i was like all of a sudden i was
like
it was exciting now like you know so you
think you can dance so all these other
dances were really for a lot of years it
was like dancing
the the secret of the dance is like
it's a gl it's a ceiling yeah where the
highest you can get is
back up dancing for something like me
and my brother we danced for mike like
oh that's
your
back of dance for michael jackson
madonna janet jackson
you did it yeah that was pretty and then
from there you know that wasn't even the
highest echelon for me for even for my
first like 10 years of dancing right
right then you got to go into
choreography or something right yeah or
but you're always background but what
you guys did what your generation did
what i loved is you guys
bursted through that ceiling and went no
no no no like we would do this we can
definitely people too but then your
names and your crews became
on par with some of the artists and you
maybe live beyond some of the artists
actually the top of the top which is
great and it becomes like doing [ __ ]
like this like we're going to see the
kanjis we're going to see jab rock
we're coming to see quest we're not
coming to see you dance behind justin
bieber mm-hmm even though you can't do
that make some money it's all [ __ ]
good but also you can open up for them
also yeah that's great it's a totally
different thing to like like for example
um even at coachella which is like
obviously a whole different that was the
first thing that we did this year that
was just like that bloomberg
yeah and it's like we're on the
coachella live stream and it says
kendra's and i'm like wow like from that
level i'm like this is the most
ridiculous [ __ ] we've ever done but even
then it's like that's just coachella so
it's like you know we had some fans but
people people aren't going to coachella
for kindred you know dude why are you
downplaying it though that's big time
i'm only saying that stage on coachella
any way shape or form you the top tier
of the artist that year
i think it's coachella
the reality is you're here right you're
[ __ ] with these a-less celebrities
who are doing it and then next week you
come to jk news and that sets the real
of like what your real world stay humble
dude you're just like all i'm saying i'm
saying it's like coachella no matter how
sick that was it's crazy because when
you go to something like head in the
clouds
it's like our community yeah so that's
something i was gonna ask you like how
does it feel performing to like
your people and thrown by like like our
people and then also it almost feels
like like you know how there's a whole
like black excellence movement it feels
like there's this giant asian excellence
movement right we randomly see michelle
yao pop up on stage you're just like
what the [ __ ] is going on that's what
made the class feel so special too right
like comparative even to like again
[ __ ] apples and orange is different
in one sentence but even at coachella
like we'll we'll hear a couple fans like
yeah kendra's you know people are down
for it ahead in the clouds it's like
people knew us you know what i mean it
was a totally different like we were
stressed the whole time i'll give the
scenario like how this even thing uh
went down this this is the most ironic
and stressful show i did all year and
the reason why it's ironic is because
since coachella we already we performed
at the 88 rising set at coachella so we
already knew we were locked in for head
in the clouds months later coachella's
in april and the clouds in august we
knew in april we're performing ahead in
the clouds we had all this time to be
like all right cool kenja's going to
perform and the original thing is we
were going to have a 10-minute slot all
right
what had happened as we got really close
is this i'm not going to say the name
but a large chinese public company came
in as a client they do apparel footwear
and stuff like that large chinese public
company they came in as a client
miniso they wanted uh
to put together because they're they're
debuting a whole new apparel line and
all that stuff so they wanted to hire us
to choreograph for artists including
people like rich brian and like you know
this other upcoming arts to put together
a set where we would rep their clothes
and shoes
and then it makes sense for them yeah
totally that would have been way better
than fashion nova yeah thank you
and in this ten minute set
right because other artists were there
we only can just
our obligation was only performed two
minutes it was my as a choreographer it
was my obligation to direct and
choreograph the whole entire thing for
10 minutes with other artists and us be
like dance and hype and stuff with them
so they're not on stage by themselves
you know they're not dancing but they
can just dance argument was two minutes
so i'm i'm leading up to the [ __ ]
show for the like the the last three
weeks
i'm back and forth with the client from
china with the account manager on our
side with 88 we're doing all this stuff
i'm choreographing so uh routines to
like respond stuff there's other artists
two songs with other artists cause this
is the whole fashion show plus dance
show they're switching songs midway
because they need to switch i'm like
[ __ ] but i gotta re-choreograph whole
numbers meanwhile kendra's only focusing
on two minutes of our own [ __ ] damn and
then remember i told you it was the
thursday before
aka one one week and some change before
the event
that suddenly political tensions because
we talked about this here scrapped it
scrapped it because pelosi brought her
heavies to taiwan exactly
dude
with china
dude because political tension this
large public facing chinese conglomerate
had to pull out from this us basis
so heavenly class was still going on but
the particular client that we had the
whole job with
that i i had hired my whole crew and
[ __ ] like that bought studio space all
this [ __ ] the world's crazy right they
just had to pull out for political
reasons sorry so big that we can't even
handle ugh so far that's crazy 14 hours
no matter how much it sucked and i had
to hit up all my guys i'm sorry man
thank you for like you know uh blocking
out your time and stuff but the gig is
canceled nobody's getting paid blah blah
blah it's like one of the shitty ass
things that you know it happens yeah did
you blame it on nancy though you should
have i kind of blamed it on her heavies
good so for a couple hours i'm like i'm
like almost as shitty as it was i like
all the anxiety and the stress went away
it's like i don't it's a force beyond my
control we can't do it it sucks but uh
whatever like great luck to everybody
else perform right yeah
i set up like a [ __ ] golf tee time
and you're like that i'm trying to like
get my head out of my game and then on
my way to see time like later on that
day
management hits me back now all right so
you guys still doing your 10 minute slot
right
oh my god so because the client bounced
out they still have the slot and so they
just assumed
miscommunication assumed but like assume
that we were big fat miscommunication on
my i'm like no way like we're one we're
less than a week like a week out i can't
put 10 minutes together when when i had
eight minutes of other no dude it's so
easy like we got just bring out three
tables
three cameras in the middle and we'll do
just kidding live in the middle of head
in the clouds bam right there yeah i
mean so you know i we have to
renegotiate you're not good at
brainstorming stay realistic you know if
we're gonna go to like even kendrick
standards like being i can't believe he
didn't call me yeah
dance with a dancer you know i'm the
greatest choreographer this was my call
to the kinships man i could have did
some bicep curls on stage
so dude
six minutes right here one minute each
we could have [ __ ] done it dude you
could have talked about macros counting
calories i would have made a protein
shake on stage you know what do we got
like like i said standards
easy
it'll take me more time to freaking pour
one from each dead homie
wow
we could have had dante fly in and [ __ ]
with his rubio outfit
i would have i want to just 10 minutes
on stage it could feel like a lifetime
guys i can do it right now
all you do is me and joe battle each
other if you play that wrong even if it
doesn't feel like a lifetime you could
choreograph it wrong where it feels like
a lifetime to the audience and that's
the bad that's worse right that's worse
well the problem is you guys count by
like five six seven eight so it's like
no [ __ ] it's gonna feel like a long time
too slow counting the wrong way
transition you need some [ __ ]
where are the quarterbacks
you know what sucks about dancers
it takes 40 of them to fill up 10
minutes it takes only me to fill up 10
minutes
yeah so anyways
like you said
you know and i want to get to some other
the juicy stuff anyway you know we had
to like pull some one piece of old
material but we didn't want to do the
same show
you know we got to wrap ourselves so in
three and we only had three rehearsals
now because
that's all i scheduled with the guys and
we had to cancel two rehearsals because
at that time the day i was supposed to
rehearse with them was the day that the
game the gig got pulled so i canceled
that day's rehearsal and the next day
and then the next day is when we get the
flight you have to do your round on the
court yeah you have to play your round
so we had to put the [ __ ] pedal to
the metal you're all at different place
now back in the 80s when we was doing it
this one was when we called time uh solo
time we're gonna break it to solo time
instant break off we're gonna break off
so everyone just goes like this
then we gotta go back in the end after
we all did like you but you gotta be out
there for a hot second don't just do one
goddamn move at any regular corporate
job easy but when it's like no no not
for sure the pressure of being the only
dance crew rep in yeah you know
yeah i want to see some [ __ ] and
everybody knows who you are you know
that's high stakes that's how i stated
yes so either way the point is on
saturday we were performing that and
like we barely literally that morning i
finished a [ __ ] transition we're like
going to the studio finish transition
get dressed then we head over and we're
performing it was like that day damn
y'all [ __ ] procrastinating you guys
can get all you guys
you procrastinate but you guys are
professionals
you don't take your work seriously get
the [ __ ] out of here
so that whole day you can't prepare
it goes by like a blur we're [ __ ]
stressed out the whole time we finish
our performance and you know how it is
you [ __ ] get on stage you blink it's
over you know what it's like to start
planning you can't hear can you hear can
you hear that i don't [ __ ] know go up
my big go up my account cause the shit's
off and there's no st we don't get a
shut down no no texting
that [ __ ]
just look
we're gonna follow you like one two then
you start dancing to someone's rhythm
that's literally what we did we brought
in we're like hey look spread out as
much as you can hit the front and at the
end of the day just back up center we
ain't got no tech time so just [ __ ]
follow [ __ ] show you guys a hundred
percent so we do that [ __ ] and then once
we're done there's so much anxiety so
everybody's just [ __ ] drunk it's a
blur [ __ ] dude but it's the next day
that the real real epic [ __ ] happened so
we had done our performance and stuff
and that was that was sick that was
already such an honor thank you 88
having a class festival everybody for
having us where can we watch it
it was we will probably upload a video
bits and pieces on guys i want to see
the whole thing dude all right all right
all right all right but all ten the next
day sunday right here's here's where the
most epic and juicy [ __ ] happened that's
going like mad viral right now you guys
performed twice so we had a secret
performance a surprise performance
with jackson wang on sunday and jackson
wang was the closer of head in the
clouds as an individual artist he's a
he's a big biggest dude there right i
know jackson literally from korea
uh both technically he's chinese but but
he he's on got7 in korea as well
he looks really young for his age he's
the man dude he's he's younger he's in
his mid-20s i thought he was 40.
oh yeah
so we we had no time obviously so we
only uh came out my boy vane was
choreographing for jackson uh his lead
choreographer for his show he did like a
30 45 minute set or something like that
and we come out for his finale number
and it's only like four eight counts so
it's like we're not
to what we were even stressed
this channel can you show them four
accounts
so we're coming in
all right we're coming in super super
just like the relief from the day prior
feeling good knowing we're gonna come
out for a surprise performance
right for the biggest star of that day
we go out there we do this number kill
it right [ __ ] great time
but what people didn't know backstage
is that when we got off and we came to
the back what jackson didn't know is we
brought him out of his camper and in
fingers backstory me and him had like
this multi-year-long agreement when he
had like eight million followers on ig
he like he was hey make a deal with you
i was all right he's like when i get 30
million followers on instagram you have
to announce that i'm a kendra
and he said that that's not that he
wanted a big one too yeah hell wanted to
be on for a long time you know he said
that like you know a lot of the kenja's
uh inspired him to really get into
dancing and like he was on like k-pop
like competition tvs back in the day
where because they do this a lot in
korea where they're like different
challenges like you have to learn dance
for me he would like off of youtube
learn different changes dance routines
and perform them for like reality tv
shows like years ago so the history runs
real rich and deep right
and the thing is for me i'm like
30 million [ __ ] all right i'll give
[ __ ] cards to whatever you want like
sure let's go kendra's for sure
and then
lo and behold like every single time
he saw me it'd be like 15 million i
remember our deal 20 million remember
25 million followers hey remember our
deal and you continue to say that i'm
like oh [ __ ]
this this is like he's pushing for it's
the real deal now he's sitting at 29.8
million followers all right by time
sunday
so there's no at the end of the day
this is the moment yeah you know i was
like look destiny is is
writing this [ __ ] story you guys are
together yeah right we're here
we [ __ ] just got on stage as a
surprise performance to close out him
closing head in the clouds which is a
big [ __ ] deal for him chinese star
came over here and just rocked it like
that
we get off stage pulling out of his
camper
and then uh we gave him this custom
one-on-one jacket we took
the signature uh we don't even have
bombers anymore can't produce him when
we're like that uh we have the signature
alibaba bomber and then we took some of
his team stuff cause that's that's his
you know his clothing line deconstructed
some of [ __ ] combined it made this
custom 101 jackson bomber we gifted tim
and that's when i announced him and you
can see this video online and stuff yeah
that's crazy that's why i announced him
like yo you know that deal blah blah
play that [ __ ] the reason why i danced
so we made a promise yes and uh this is
one of those moments where uh when you
had like eight million followers
right now we want to formally and
officially ask you to join the crew and
this fool literally like drops to his
knees and he's like so honored about it
like we're like chanting together and
stuff like that we would love to
formally and finally actually ask you to
officially get down and become a member
of the campaign
[Applause]
we dropped this video right and
literally it starts going viral it
becomes the number one trending thing on
weibo in china wow i nev we have never
hit yeah number one trending anywhere
like that before we we like top 10 on
weibo before and we're already jumping
for joy
number one [ __ ] trending like it's
got millions of views on on my social
media accounts on his account and stuff
like that and the crazy thing is
i'm so just like blown away by how his
fans are rallying and all the comments
the crazy things nobody's like yo
congrats kendricks you got everybody's
like yo like we're so happy for jackson
to like have the support and have the
encouragement of like his brothers that
like push him to further his own like
you know stretch his limits for like his
dance journey
like to to be comfortable and to be like
honored with such like uh inclusion
is rallying behind the fact that like
it's a wonderful thing to have for him
in his life
so i'm literally just like it's one of
the most mind-blowing experiences
because for us you get it it's just like
this is our relationship has just gotten
so real so authentic so close we [ __ ]
love this guy we've been working with
him constantly for like years and stuff
he's always been family to us
but the rest of the world the way they
perceive it as well which is in in their
truth as well is like this is such a
huge and amazing thing for him and i'm
like holy [ __ ]
i thought it was just amazing thing for
us yeah yeah but really it's this
beautiful mutual thing where like what
he gets from what we get from it like is
is just actual bond but in an official
way it's not like this mutual like this
business transactional like we do work
it's like hey like regardless all that
[ __ ] for the rest of our lives i'm gonna
call you crude you're gonna be fam to me
you ever need anything you know what i
mean and we just were able to
officialize in that moment so that's an
amazing story that's dope man that's
awesome i want to make a wager with you
[ __ ]
so now that means i'll never be a king
dude when jk news
loses
another million subscribers i want you
to promise me you will announce that i
am a kinja
because i'm going to need something else
this [ __ ] ain't going to be working for
me jake would you he loses another
million hey nick end the video bro
every so often he's gonna be like hey we
lost another hundred thousand times we
lost two thousand dollars
y'all should be like you know dude when
you guessed it on the thing private
guess then when all sudden middle at the
end of it someone takes off the mask and
it's [ __ ] homeboy jackson went like
oh [ __ ] he's been in the crew the whole
[ __ ] time he's so gangster what if
jackson was like
jabberwocky and then you're like oh [ __ ]
and he's like just kidding i'm really a
kenja and he does this so stupid
if he missed he missed the next
rehearsal and he goes jackson you're out
of the crew bro
yeah jackson you're always [ __ ] late
you're always [ __ ] late it's like
number one training all the way but oh
yeah he just got kicked out actually
miss rehearsal because he's in korea
couldn't fly out had a show
jackson's always late dude you know what
i'll say you're like crazy weekend then
that weekend huh you had a crazy ass it
was a wild weekend and you know what you
know obviously it's not just about like
a deal or a bet or anything you know but
but it is dope that like one
i'm a man of my word regardless how
crazy it is i'm mad at my word but two
duffle is a matter of his word too
that's that's ty and he didn't have to
keep it on his end he's such a superstar
yeah but he genuinely wanted it i feel
like and in the video the thing is
[ __ ] funny that you can see the
hominess is like literally he he's
[ __ ] honored he like drops he comes
back up he's like he's like kendra's is
an artist i'm like whatever the [ __ ] you
want cuz obviously you know he's not
gonna dance with us all the time
[Applause]
five times salary for everyone what's
the current salary if it's zero then
people
you